I mean I'm not very flexible but this is
doable
hey GQ my name is Tim honey I'm a car
fabricator and you are watching the
breakdown so this is transformers wow
it's such a Transformers fan it's just
like exactly what led me into building
cars this is a huge engine this engine
would never belong in this crusty crusty
card you can actually see there's like
bead rolling on the side of the fender
wells like this is definitely never in
that car this is like photo edited in
there but that is a humongous probably
like a 500cc summit engine but those
little guys
sticking out those are called
independent throttle bodies each
cylinder has its own carburetor and
those those little squiggly lines on top
those are fuel lines and so that's
usually that's meant for like a massive
amount of gas and air and that's like
those like top fuel engines that doesn't
belong in there totally wrong carburetor
that's pretty impressive yeah
so she's talking about high-rise headers
so that goes the headers go above the
engine for engines that produce a lot of
horsepower they work so fast that they
don't need a big exhaust and it doesn't
really matter they're really loud so
it's usually meant for like race cars
you wouldn't you wouldn't have that on a
street car you can go faster oh you go
fast
typically like only high-performance
cars have double pumpers initially on
carburetors there's always something
that sprays a little bit of gas in but
then on high-performance cars these they
can have a secondary pump which sprays a
bunch more gas in you know all an engine
is is basically harnessing explosions so
more fire more air bigger explosion it
looks like you're at your distributor
caps a little
loose your distributor capitals loose
that's that is your points you probably
wouldn't have a distributor cap if you
add that engine
you'd have electronic ignition or timing
or something like that
you wouldn't have this huge big engine
and it just have this like old
antiquated distributor cap but your
distributor cap is is basically this
thing inside your engine that's this
round thing is what all the spark plugs
go from and inside is basically a little
thing that spins and each time it spins
and hits this contact point is what
sends the spark to the spark plug
did your car wouldn't be going anywhere
the distributor cap coming a little
loose that probably wouldn't happen that
huge engine fitting inside of that
engine bay pushing it but probably could
be other than that it's actually fairly
accurate okay let's run that they think
he has 5,000 horsepower which is like
ridiculous
his engine would be sticking out of his
hood it'd be humongous five thousand
horsepower is useless in a streetcar
because you wouldn't get any traction
you need humongous tires
[Music]
even even the Bentley shooting a little
thing off of it and Bentley probably
would fold in half it's like made out of
aluminum stretch them out
hold them so the rock is driving this
this international that car would
probably pull all the rest of those cars
so like that International has is like a
big diesel motor and it's just like
meant for hauling like 18 wheelers and
you know like 40,000 pounds and all
those cars they all they would do is
just flip around and that that diesel
engine would just yank all those cars
away your horsepower is only directly
proportionate to your traction if you
have really big tires and really are
sorry really big rims and really small
tires you don't get a lot of traction
that's why I like f1 cars have really
big thick tires you need your need your
tire to actually kind of flex and bend a
little bit to actually get traction or
else all you're doing is just kind of
skipping and spinning it on the street
and this is a Jaguar that Jason
statements and his tires are catching on
fire yeah I think your brakes would
catch on fire I mean like listen if you
if you sit and you do a burnout in a car
eventually it's gonna eat away all the
rubber it's gonna get really hot once in
a while they'll catch fire but like and
then they'll just pop the tire and then
now you're just done your rim you just
melted your tire off
[Music]
nós this company called nas all it is is
it allows more oxygen into your engine
if you have more oxygen and more gas in
your engine bigger the explosion hotter
the explosion so adding nos to it is
like a sneaky way of getting more oxygen
into your combustion chamber so having
two huge tanks like that would be
ridiculous
you only need one so fire coming out of
the back yeah that's that's reasonable
when you have fire that comes out of the
back that typically doesn't happen while
you're accelerating it happens while
you're decelerating because some of the
spent gases in your exhaust catch fire
and then come out the back of the
exhaust like it if you ever seen a
really fast car going down the highway
and you'll see like a blip of a fire
coming to the back that's usually
because their mixture is a little off
and they have a little residual gas in
their exhaust and so what's happening
here is it's got tons of gas and air
going into this 5,000 horsepower engine
that would mean that fire was happening
inside the engine and then continually
going down the exhaust which is Jesus is
a horrible thing for that to happen
those bellies are like made out of
nothing
yeah alright no pause up there that's
like a 5,000 pound car flipping a 5,000
pound cars very very difficult I don't
care how many like tethered what have
these it's like next to impossible to
flip a Bentley like you can drive it
like a total [ __ ] and it's not gonna
it just won't roll over so it's flipping
front way over
I'd say that's impossible
doors come off easily whenever you want
your door to pop off your car all you
gotta do is just give it a nudge that's
totally totally true yeah yeah cars do
that all the time yeah
cars flip this way all the time
stationary
totally I like that if on this freeze
frame it looks like his wheels are bent
in so like whatever comes after this
shot if his car is still moving that
would be impossible if you had your
wheels bent like that that would mean
that your axles broke or your rear-end
broke or you're in a movie and it's not
real but it is
okay thanks Wow there it is yeah look so
if you stop it you can see on the bottom
of the car nothing is attached so
there's no subframe this car has a frame
typically and that car doesn't have a
frame which is weird and then it had
some a drive shaft and it also looks
like it has no engine oh and then also
it they CGI'd a an exhaust that has a
cross crisscross which is which is good
but they like forgot some stuff I like
good movies and fast and furious it's
not like a good movie but it's terribly
entertaining if this is fueling
somebody's imagination and this is
inspiring I think that's great I mean it
actually like one spot of time like when
Fast and Furious one came out it like
revitalized the car industry the United
States was bedrock in these like Mopar
muscle cars and you learn from you pop
in the back yard and things and and now
became like what fuel injector sizes in
like five an inline four and I have a
turbo and these movies helped that
industry most everything in this whole
scene is totally unrealistic
this is clip from the first fast and
furious
my dad filter I hope your horse is a
Detroit muscle alright so he says nine
hundred horsepower of Detroit muscle
that very well could be true so what
he's got on top is something called a
whipple supercharger and then he's got
what looks like a huge bit big block
this is like abnormally large
supercharger superchargers essentially
shoot compressed air into your
combustion chamber so when you add
compressed gas or rather colder
compressed air and a lot of gas you have
a way bigger explosion so if you've ever
had to like a campfire and you're
sitting the blow air underneath that's
what a compressor doesn't especially
that one this was like the tough guy car
like if you had like a supercharger and
the best part is like there's no way get
that under your hood so then you'd have
to cut out a hole and then once upon a
time it was Dodge that had these things
called the the shaker hoods but yeah all
of this stuff was real and this car
actually in real life is I mean it was
it was a real car and it really did have
nine under her spare know what she ran
in Palmdale no what does she run nine
seconds flat nine second flat car is
like ridiculously fast so he's talking
about quarter-mile times running your
car in a quarter mile in 9 seconds your
car could run a 36 second mile that's a
fast car you're going 145 miles an hour
in a quarter of a mile I doubt that that
car could do that but maybe if it's a
nine second car then that's that's
amazing I was driving so much torque the
chassis twisted coming off the wall so
he's talking about there's so much
torque in this that the chassis twists
that actually happens even if you add
annoying 900 horsepower on that frame
which is like dinky piece of steel they
just literally twist and you'd see the
car it would just be like bent a little
bit or drive sideways down the road like
this that's weird
torque is a better description of
horsepower and so when they when they're
talking about torque in terms of how
much
pound foot-pounds torque a car has
that's a better description of how much
power it has so like if you have 900
horsepower car but you can't get any
traction and your car doesn't have very
much torque your engine has a lot of
torque your car might not have a lot of
torque and like if you have a lot too
much torque on a car it'll just lift up
that scene was surprisingly totally
realistic and even Paul Walker's
reaction to that engine it's just like
oh thank you
don't check I'd be the same way so next
up we have my cousin Vinnie equal time
ox head positraction can't make those
marks without positraction which was not
available on the 64 buick skylark
she's talking about something called
posi traction cars in the 70s and 60s
they they had a fixed axle rear end and
there was only three cars that had
independent rear suspension and so the
idea behind having independent rear
suspension is that you have your wheels
are on the ground more you have better
traction and this whole scene is about
that the tires are even which mean that
you would have to have independent rear
suspension I find it hard to believe you
could tell by looking at a photo of tire
marks right like a car peeling out and
going really fast and laying down a
bunch of rubber you'd need to know your
stuff to know this movie came out in
like the 90s right and she's talking
about cars from the 60s but she's
actually wrong in this she said two cars
I did three car said it had a regular
differential which anyone who's been
stuck in the mud in Alabama knows you
step on the gas once I his fins the
other tides has not been that was
correct so what she's describing if it
has a limited slip differential limited
slip means that this is your engine your
drive chef comes back it goes into your
differential that gearbox I was talking
about and with a limited slip it allows
one wheel to torque differently than
another wheel and the idea is that you
want to maintain power so let's say I'm
going over a bump this rotates faster
just for a minute then this wheel does
if you had a fixed sex
right without a limited-slip both of
these would rotate at the same amount
and so you would see that break in tire
marks had a solid veer accident so when
the left tire will go up on the curb the
right time would tilt out and ride along
its edge but that didn't happen here
the time ox stayed flat and even this
car had an independent rear suspension
Mike future wife right there no so she
she's describing something it's 100%
accurate again when you have independent
suspension this tire goes up and it's
still maintaining traction and this
one's just going on it's level surface
right here this these tires are capable
spinning and moving at the same kind of
forward momentum and that's only
achievable with a limited slip or
independent rear suspension there were
only two other cars made in America that
had positraction and independent rear
suspension and enough power to make
these marks one was the Corvette the
other was the 1963 Pontiac Tempest and
the Corvair Corvair was a rear engined
American car that they they wanted to
make it into like a muscle car but it
was like kind of it's more like European
also had an independent rear suspension
also that same year my cousin Vinnie is
is like iconically accurate on
everything she's describing and her
accent is also pretty spot-on
too
this is pineapple Express I did a race
once upon a time that the entire race
was backwards it's only one gear going
backwards so you don't go very fast but
yeah you could totally drive a car
backwards long as you want I think they
were trying to show in the movie how
like relatively slow it was going it
wasn't like an exaggerated Hollywood
bump but like those cars are actually
meant to they used to have like pusher
bars and they were designed they're
reinforced in the front so they could
push cars out of the way both cars made
out of just like really thin 18 gauge
steel and so if you shoot a car nothing
would happen there just bounce around
and the gas can no cars don't really
explode anymore like if I were to take a
gas tank of a car and light it it would
just shoot flames out of the top but it
wouldn't explode but when you see a car
explode it's typically out it's when
it's compressed compressed gas explodes
like for fuel injection if you have that
that captures fire or something or you
hit somebody on the side of their car
and the gas lines right there yeah
that'll kind of explode what wouldn't
probably happen is that the bullet would
pierce the metal and it wouldn't ignite
anything all it would do is just make a
hole and then gas would start dumping
out I'm not very flexible but this seems
doable windows on cars are tempered but
they have safety glass in them so
windshields and sideview glass are
different I think it was back in like
the 70s the United States made that all
windshields need to be safety glass so
if something hits it it'll shatter so it
doesn't have like really sharp pieces of
glass so you're like get stabbed on if
you look at it from a you know funny
angle you'll see it has like kind of a
wavy line to it and that's because
there's plastic inside of it and they
sandwich two pieces of tempered glass
and that's what makes a windshield it's
designed to not collapse on the driver
that glass would be like you could just
punch right through it after a bullet
goes through by itself yep pretty
impossible to just punch through it
you would break your hand let's fast
forward a little
[Music]
yeah launching a car in there you gotta
have like a ramp and for the car to like
stay perfect and land like that a
bazillion different things have to go
right for that to happen typically your
car when you're accelerating the
rotating force of your car pitches it
forward a little bit your car needs
enough energy to go off and then
gradually come down so we're doing that
off of a bag of garbage probably not
probably wouldn't work like that
and then air bags air bags have this gas
this really shitty toxic gas inside and
that's what they explode on impact it's
just like this little trigger mechanism
that happens in the front of the car I
don't think you would be like playfully
like playing with it like it flees your
arms out and it's supposed to inhibit
your ability to move that's the whole
idea of it so I came driving and just
kind of like beating on it that's not
true
this is the movie rat-race driving this
amazing Bronco I've got this is actually
a pretty good movie if it's strong
enough to just keep on going and pulling
then that's a tow rope that is using in
theory it should be able to do exactly
what it's doing which is yank it on up
there we put winches on off-road cars
your winch should be more powerful than
the poundage of your car so if your car
weighs 4,500 pounds you should have a
winch that is capable of pulling more
than 4,500 paths so if you want to test
that out
you just hook your car into a tree and
flick it on and then your car goes
hanging in the tree like you can see
there's like a little lift underneath
the car
that rope is stronger than that metal so
like the that big metal radar thing
would break off before the rope would
snap
I mean tow ropes are supposed to take
like 20,000 pounds or something like
that so like you're supposed to be able
to hook multiple cars on you know like
if you're off-roading and you need to
get your buddy's rig out of the mud it's
not just the weight of his truck that
you got to get it's the weight of
however much it's stuck
says that multiplied by how much force
is grabbing onto the truck hanging from
the steering wheel is totally possible
goes through your firewall and then it
goes to your steering box that's metal
on metal on metal and there's many bolts
that hold that in place but that being
said race cars you have to remove the
steering wheel typically because you got
to get out of the car and by the
underneath of that car I think it's
actually a real car and I think they
hoisted up a real car it looked like
there was like a little track system
underneath the car that's probably for
safety reasons like you know just in
case I rope did break or maybe that rope
isn't actually doing that so this is
absolutely ridiculous Hollywood kind of
fantasy but totally feasible
next up we have x-men Dark Phoenix
[Applause]
there's all that tempered-glass of a
second of that I don't know about
launching like that but like I would
think that everything would just come to
a dead stop typically to launch a car
you need something that's creating lift
so if you're gonna hit just on the edge
of it I would think that they would just
hit and spin off let's rewind that okay
so it's up in the air and then it now
it's spinning the other way because it
was spinning this way so now it's
spinning this way all right so it's
already defied gravity and now it's
deciding to hit and roll over it looks
like they like might have really crashed
a car and then just like stuck some
cameras in there that looks that looks
really real and if they didn't that's
amazing CGI or whatever
so this has gone in 60 seconds
[Music]
so pulling the ignition out of a
cylinder actually does work on older
cars if you look at a modern-day key and
I'll have a dot on it and if it has a
dot that means it has a microchip in it
and that means that when you put your
key in your car it sends a signal to the
computer that says we're friends and we
can do this old cars there's really only
like three wires and so if you pulled
that out you could stick a screwdriver
and just spin it
[Music]
so okay so that that car has a coded key
and what she's doing it says she's
sticking the there is a Ferrari recoding
key it's really expensive you don't get
it if you're for our dealership and it's
so you can recoat keys normally when you
your Ferrari doesn't start and you lost
the keys they tow it back to the Ferrari
dealership and they give you a new ECU
which is your computer of your car and
then they give you a new locking
mechanism like five or ten thousand
dollars depending on what year your car
is it's ridiculously expensive so if you
own a Ferrari
don't lose your keys so she's pressed a
button and that is a starter switch so
that's the thing that we use and to
start engines when you're like testing
engines so when you do the starter you
plug that into the starter motor itself
which is attached to the engine so when
you're pressing the trigger button that
means that either you don't want to go
inside and start it yourself
or you don't have somebody else to help
you or it's because you don't know which
wire to spin but on a modern car you
wouldn't be using the trigger without
the key in without it program the car
won't start it cuts off it has a
fail-safe in it so like modern Ferraris
are actually pretty clever
they cut the fuel line off as well as a
disabling the ignition so they're big
pain in the ass that's why like if
you're stealing a Ferrari it's because
you either have the key or you are
holding the person ransom
okay so this is planes trains and
automobiles
[Applause]
this car is a Buick LeSabre and it was
like The Tortoise like the ugliest car
ever created but they would never break
down they were so like over built so
right before this this car was on fire
and and like surprisingly still kicking
this looks like that just a roof caught
on fire the back end of the car but like
it being that I'm fire and driving
around possible so good signals like the
wheel is wobbling so when do your wheels
wobble that's it's either because your
wheels are not balanced properly or
they're not on correctly so the car like
moving steadily I mean that's it's
obviously real it just means that that
poor car has been through a lot so he's
got a donut on the rear just and then
he's got his wheels wobbly looks like
that donuts more stable than the actual
wheels
it looks like the side panels from the
Woodie it's kind of like just having a
campfire and on the side of your car
with any degree of accuracy exactly how
fast we were going 78 miles an hour I
don't think that car could got 78 miles
an hour with two wobbly wheels and a
donut he only supposed to go like 30
miles an hour on him it says it on it
there's a little piece of rubber and
it's like not that much air in them
you're supposed to just like hobble off
the road so like continue to drive on
one going 78 miles an hour I wouldn't do
that
you got no outside mirror no we lost
that you have no functioning gauges no
not a one however the radio still works
I mean you could get rid of all of the
your instrument panel still work let's
die I mean the instrument panel is just
telling you what's what's happening in
the engine and things like that like how
fast or how many maybe your oil pressure
or your your vaults and your charging
system but like generally speaking
that's just showing you what's going on
it's not doing anything other than just
that display so you can technically trip
all of that out of your car and your car
will still
keep on going we watched a bunch of car
Clips today I hope you liked it as much
as I did nice watching
[Music]